nach fünf jahren ist die kinderlähmung
die einen grausamen tod bringen kann
nach europa zurückgekehrt
mehr zu der krankheit und was dagegen
unternommen werden kann erfahrt ihr
jetzt bei klick zum salzen fiction
wenn von lähmungen gesprochen wird
denken viele menschen an die folgen von
unfällen oder an ursachen die mit
erbinformationen oder komplikationen bei
der geburt aufgetreten sind selten wird
an infektionen gedacht gegen viele
infektionen kann man sicher schließlich
impfen lassen das gilt eigentlich auch
für die kinderlähmung so einfach wie das
klingt ist es aber nicht es gibt
verschiedene arten von methoden zu
impfen zum einen gibt es die methode mit
einem lebend impfstoff und zum anderen
gibt es die mit einem tod im stoff hier
in deutschland wird ausschließlich mit
einem tod im stoff gearbeitet in der
ukraine dagegen kommt der lebend im
stoff zum einsatz dieser brachte den
menschen wahrscheinlich die tödliche
krankheit zurück ins land
wie kann ein impfstoff der ja eigentlich
dafür da ist menschen zu schützen
krankheiten auslösen dazu muss man
wissen was die ihm stoffe im körper
bewirken kurz gesagt man spritzt den
menschen die wegen einer krankheit gegen
die geimpft werden soll der leben im
stoff besteht wie der name schon sagt
aus lebenden aber nicht
krankheitsauslösenden wären der tod dem
stoff spielt den körper mit toten wären
eine echte infektion vor in beiden
fällen soll das immunsystem des körpers
antikörper dagegen ausbilden jetzt gibt
es aber ein entscheidendes problem bei
der methode mit den lebenden wehren kann
es passieren dass diese ähnlich wie das
immunsystem sich weiterentwickeln und in
der fachsprache wird das vaccine
assoziierte parasitische poliomyelitis
bezeichnet folge die harmlosen viren
entwickeln sich zu ernsthaften gefahren
für die geimpften und deren
kontaktpersonen mittendrin in einer
solchen gefahr die ukraine
zwei kleine ukrainische kinder das eine
vier jahre das andere zehn monate als in
vor zwei monaten an polio der
kinderlähmung erkrankt sie haben sie
vermutlich an anderen die mit einem
lebend impfstoff geimpft worden sind
infiziert und hatten selbst auch keinen
lückenlosen impfschutz polio ist eine
der infektionskrankheiten die
todbringende lähmung hervorrufen kann
die polio viren stören beziehungsweise
zerstören das zentrale nervensystem
die weltgesundheitsorganisation teilte
mit dass vor ganzen fünf jahren der
letzte polio vorfall auf europäischer
ebene gemeldet worden
ist die krankheit war also eigentlich
ausgerottet wie konnte es passieren dass
es jetzt neue fälle gibt ersten
vermutungen zur folge sei sowohl die
lebende methode als auch die mangelnde
impfrate in der ukraine grund für die
rückkehr der todbringenden krankheit
wenn nicht geimpft wurde kann sich an
geimpften anstecken und wer geimpft wird
kann krank werden zitat diese krankheit
hat das potenzial für epidemien so der
sprecher des politikers zehn trupps der
weltgesundheitsorganisation oliver
rosenbauer
das problem ist nicht dass impfen und
dass der ein oder andere krank wird weil
wenn alle geimpft sind kann sich dann
trotzdem die polio nicht weiter
ausbreiten aber wenn zusammen kommt dass
der eine oder andere daran erkrankt und
es nicht geimpfte menschen gibt dann
besteht eine große gefahr der
ausbreitung der epidemie
die lange inkubationszeit macht es den
medizinern ähnlich wie bei ebola schwer
nachzuvollziehen wo und wann sich die
betroffenen beispielsweise durch eine
schmierinfektion angesteckt haben die
zeit liegt bei bis zu 35 tagen
wenn der virus land tatsächlich das
zentrale nervensystem erreicht hat
leiden die betroffenen unter folgendem
beim stadium der nicht paralympischen
poliomyelitis klagen sie über fieber
rückenschmerzen einem steifen nacken und
muss muskel spasmen also muskelkrämpfen
sind mehrere tage vergangen tritt das
stadium der paralympischen poliomyelitis
dort kann es zu schlimmen beschwerden
kommen das fieber steigt und paralyse
nehmen die betroffenen in ihre gewalt
und der paralyse versteht man
lähmungserscheinungen all diese leiden
gibt es keine medikation
es gibt lediglich die präventive impfung
eben gegen die kinderlähmung aber auch
die kann wie beim beispiel der ukraine
sehen konnten nicht immer schützen
bereits infizierte menschen versucht man
mit psychotherapeutische symptomatischer
und orthopädischer therapie zu helfen ja
was könnt ihr zu eurem schutz und zum
schutz anderer menschen tun
lasst euch impfen lasst euch in
deutschland impfen
auch wenn eine impfung möglicherweise
keinen hundertprozentigen schutz bietet
bietet sie uns menschen die möglichkeit
krankheiten wirklich die stirn zu bieten
nur wenn sich alle impfen lassen kann
eine krankheit wirklich eingedämmt
werden auch wenn er im friesischen
bestehen das risiko wirklich schwer zu
erkranken ohne eine impfung ist viel
viel größer finanziellen problemen
können wir auch ganz einfach die stirn
bieten um dagegen gewappnet zu sein habe
ich jetzt noch etwas ganz besonders
solchen das heer ist der eigentlich
einfach bulli von volkswagen financial
services auf dem kanal bin ich nämlich
jetzt auch zu sehen die kollegen habe
ich mich gefragt ob ich nicht lust hätte
finanzthemen genauso einfach zu erklären
wie wissenschaftliche themen auf fixum
und diese herausforderung habe ich
natürlich sehr gerne angenommen
allerdings werde ich unterstützt von den
experten von volkswagen financial
services die themen erklären wie zum
beispiel wie bezahle ich mit dem
smartphone wie sprich auf eine weltreise
wie funktioniert das mit der
autofinanzierung und so weiter und so
fort das ganze ohne fachchinesisch das
verspreche ich euch schaut also auf dem
kanal von volkswagen financial services
vorbei und abonniert
am besten